et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
guillaume larrivé bonjour je merci
beaucoup d'être avec mon député l'yonne
membres des républicains on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre au donjon fabrice des journaux
du groupe ebra
les journaux régionaux de l'est de la
france on commence guillaume larrivé
avec cette panne massive des numéros
d'urgence qui pourraient avoir conduit à
la mort de plusieurs personnes on parle
d'au moins quatre personnes dont un bébé
de 28 mois en vendée alors c'est trop
tôt pour tirer des conclusions c'est ce
que dit le gouvernement il ya un audit
qui a été demandé par le gouvernement
est-ce que vous souhaitez qu'il ya une
commission d enquête parlementaire pour
comprendre ce qui a dysfonctionné non
pas une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire puisque montre je crois
cet incident très grave
c'est notre extrême vulnérabilité à
l'endroit des systèmes d'information et
des techniques rené barjavel autrefois
dans un roman bien connu qui s'intitule
et ravage avait expliqué très bien très
bien cela voilà on est très vulnérable
lorsque des systèmes d'information
dysfonctionne du sujet je n'ai pas
d'autres informations que celles qui ont
été communiqués publiquement
naturellement je crois que les instances
gouvernementales ont réagi comme il le
fallait je les ai dans mon département
de l'yonne
les cellules de crise ont été mises en
oeuvre comme elle devait l'être ça
plaide quand même pour beaucoup plus de
proximité et dans l'yonne pour le coup
je suis ici dans une émission des
territoires donc je parle de mon
département nous plaidons depuis des
mois pour qu'on regroupe le 15 et le 18
à auxerre et qu'on arrive à un numéro
unique avec une plateforme commune
pompiers samu sexuellement l'assemblée
des départements de france c'est
vraiment ce que nous demandons
rs locales aussi s'y oppose et je pense
que cet épisode d'une extrême gravité
quand il ya peut-être trois quatre cinq
six personnes qui sont décédées du fait
de ce problème plaide pour beaucoup plus
de progressivité nationaliser aussi le
numéro des urgences
en tout cas moi je plaide pour des
solutions territoriale lorsqu'un
consensus des acteurs de terrain
il faut les écouter en réalité ça
changerait pas grand chose si c'est un
problème d'opérateurs qu'il y avait un
problème technique en effet arrêté
repaissent interpelle le fait que nos
opérateurs comme ça défaillant blocs
finalement tout un système au niveau
national fin ni vous ni moi ne sommes
ingénieur télécoms si comme l'a très
bien expliqué hier stéphane richard
n'est un plantage informatique et un
plantage informatique voilà dans un
monde idéal j'aimerais qu'ils aient des
systèmes dits de backup qui permet de
doublonner les choses d'après ce que je
comprends il ya eu six instruments
techniques qui ont implanté en même
temps voilà enfin moi pas je suis pas
ingénieur télécoms encore une fois si
vous voulez des renseignements
techniques sur le sujet je pense que je
suis pas le bon interlocuteur
on va parler du tour de france 2 manuel
macron fabrice emmanuel macron prend le
pouls de la france un tour de france
entamé il a raison de prendre le pouls
de la france c'est un instinct grand
classique
tous les présidents de la république de
la troisième de la 4è comme de la 5e ont
fait des voyages en province et
l'expression qu'on employait au temps de
la troisième république
maintenant on appelle ça des
déplacements moi je me souviens il ya il
ya pile dix ans j'étais conseiller pour
les collectivités locales les affaires
juridiques à l'elysée d'un présent dans
le public s'appelait nicolas sarkozy en
2011 et c'est tout à fait légitime
je me rappelle l'avoir accompagné cinq
six dix fois sur le terrain au contact
des élus au contact des français tout
c'est tout à fait normal
je n'entrerai pas pour tout prix le
calendrier mix secondaires ou tertiaires
ou quaternaire que sage qui consiste à
dire le président de la république
devrait pas aller sur le terrain mais
aussi parce que s'il y allait pas en
dire il est enfermé à l'elysée je trouve
ça tout à fait normal qu'ils se
déplacent au calendrier on est en pleine
campagne électorale
non ça vous pose pas de problème ia par
n'y a pas de devoir de réserve du
président de la république ou des hommes
politiques ou des responsables dans le
débat public
il faut naturellement faire attention à
un devoir de réserve des ministres en
période électorale il ya plein devoir de
réserve c'est pas le terme exact période
effectivement qui implique par exemple
que les préfets ou les fonctionnaires
enfin pour revenir la question pour vous
juste le calendrier ne nous pose pas
problème
non enfin vous je trouve que c'est
normal qu'ils aient un contact du
président de la république avec des avec
des avec des élus j'espère qu'il aura la
possibilité d'aller dans des
départements contrastée pour sentir un
peu la réalité du pays en même temps
c'est bien ce que c'est qu'un voyage
présidentiel c'est toujours très
contrastées il est allé dans l'autre je
pense qu'il faut qu'il aille partout il
faut qu'il aille en banlieue dans des
endroits difficiles vraiment lieu par
exemple pourquoi pas et en bourgogne il
est allé récemment dans dans la nièvre
enfin je pense que ça s'est plutôt
plutôt intéressant même si je n'attends
pas de ses voyages en effet miraculeux
mais je pense est utile alors en tout
cas il ya des déclarations lors de ses
voyages notamment sur la réforme des
retraites il a remis le débat sur la
table il a dit que la réforme des
retraites ne pourrait pas être prise en
l'état vous êtes d'accord avec ça je me
suis opposé cet étrange réforme qui
avait été proposé il ya 18 mois
parce qu'elles étaient de mon point de
vue d'une complexité absolument
effarante et
monsieur delevoye tous afin avait
tellement capable de nous l'expliquer je
pense que la réforme telle qu'elle avait
été conçue il ya 18 mois n'était
vraiment pas bonne mais bien évidemment
je dis comme d'autres depuis des années
que nous n'échapperons pas à la
nécessité de reparamétrer le système de
retraite par répartition précisément
pour sauvegarder ce régime dont à la
réforme telle qu'envisagée pour vous pas
une réforme systémique mais une réforme
paramétrique c'est à dire au delà même
du régime
au delà des mots ce que nous savons vous
et moi c'est que qu'il ya de plus en
plus de personnes au delà des mots on
est dans la philosophie de la réforme
des retraites est ce que pour vous ça
doit être une informe ses mix de les
poser la question c'est y répondre à
l'âge est compris le jeu donc je dis
qu'on a un problème démographique
absolument évident bon face à ce
problème démographique
il n'ya pas 49 solutions et demi
évidemment il faut réussir à cotiser
globalement plus longtemps ça suppose de
bouger un certain nombre de paramètres
première réforme moi je pense qu'il faut
progressivement aller vers l'idée que la
retraite entre guillemets à taux plein
ce liquide à peu près vers 64 65 ans
dans ces eaux-là ensuite on peut donc
repousser l'âge de départ premièrement
deuxièmement s'agissant des régimes
spéciaux plutôt que de ne rien faire
moi je préférerais qu'on se lance dans
la fameuse clause dite du grand-père
disons que pour les nouveaux entrants on
supprime les régimes spéciaux on les
fait converger vers le régime général
je pense qu'il ya moyen de trouver
quelque chose d'à peu près raisonnable
qui devrait rassembler tous les français
de bonne volonté qui doivent comprendre
et qui comprenne je le vois bien sur le
terrain qu'on pourra pas rester avec un
système de retraite tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui sans l'heureux paramétrer et
un enjeu énorme de finances publiques
vous savez qu'on à 120% désormais de
dette publique on a été amené à beaucoup
dépensé récemment il faudra bien qu'on
atterrisse on va on va en parler mais
juste sur la réforme des retraites vous
dit les français comprennent ça veut
dire qu'on peut la relancer dès
maintenant pour vous cette réforme des
retraites dès cette année mais pourquoi
pas il faut pas faire de fétichisme du
quinquennat si j'ose dire il y aura
effectivement dans un peu moins de 300
jours des échéances une
nouvelle élection présidentielle puis
des élections à l'assemblée nationale
mais on va pas se tourner les pouces
pendant 300 jours je souhaitais caf a
relancé et aulnoye je pense qu'un jour
ce serait intéressant qu'on
démontrer aux français que comme député
comme sénateurs les membres du parlement
continue à travailler moi j'aimerais
qu'on vote en effet oui une réforme des
retraites qui permettent de les
sauvegarder
bon ça qu'on va pas vous et vos qui
justement le déficit qui s'est accrue du
fait notamment de la pandémie
un budget rectificatif 20 milliards vous
le vôtre et je vais regarder
attentivement il a été présenté mercredi
ce que je crois profondément petit 1
c'est qu'il fallait investir de l'argent
public dans la relance
j'espère que ça a été vraiment bien fait
sur l'innovation sur les filières
d'avenir et qu'on n'a pas gaspillé
d'argent public toujours des petites
interrogations sur le pilotage la mise
en oeuvre concrète de la relance enfin
globalement j'ai voté le plan de relance
petit à petit 2 maintenant il va falloir
progressivement retiré la perfusion
d'argent public
moi je ne suis pas socialiste je suis
plutôt libérale je ne pense pas que
l'économie doivent éternellement vivre
sous perfusion de subventions
globalement que c'est l'état d'esprit de
bruno le maire est pour l'essentiel je
suis en accord de la politique
économique de bruno le maire depuis
quatre ans quitter kiel ministre de
l'économie des finances donc globalement
je pense que c'est la bonne approche
maintenant le diable se niche souvent
dans les détails
j'observe à la lecture d'un rapport de
la cour des comptes que les dépenses
hors que vides ont elles aussi beaucoup
augmenté ces derniers temps et ça
j'aimerais qu'on corrige le tir
un mois je ne perds pas de vue la
nécessité de maîtriser les dépenses
publiques parce que je pense que cette
question de la dette existe il n'ya pas
d'argent magique
l'hélicoptère monétaire c'est-à-dire
cette politique monétaire extrêmement
accommodante de la banque centrale
européenne l'hélicoptère monétaire il va
devoir atterrir un jour on aura pas
d'argent magique éternellement tout ça
ça n'existe pas à ce jour il doit
arriver quand parce que le gouvernement
ne présente pas pour le moment de plan
de remboursement serait donc ce déficit
vous dites il faut le présenter
rapidement
je pense que dans les 12 mois qui
viennent il faut qu'on soit capable de
présenter une stratégie pluriannuelle de
maîtrise raisonnable des finances
publiques c'est pas du tout de la langue
de bois ça fait à dire pour vous oui
parce qu'on voit bien ce qui se passe on
a eu une dépression économique
extrêmement forte en 2020 avec une
récession de l'ordre d'à peu près de 9%
du pib
désormais on a une reprise à séville on
a de la croissance je crois que ça sera
de l'ordre de 4 et 8 5% dans la honte
pour la zone euro tant mieux pour ce
courant sont qu'à sept reprises par un
atterrissage budgétaires trop brutales
mais il faut bien quand même qu'on
réussisse à retrouver un rythme de
croisière un petit peu plus raisonnables
donc ça suppose comme on dit non tant
langues régionales ni en patois breton
mais en anglais ça suppose du fine
tuning
voilà ça suppose un peu de un peu de un
peu de subtilité dans la manière de
gérer des finances mais il va falloir le
faire et je crois que c'est plutôt
l'état d'esprit de bruno le maire une
question fermée
il va falloir le faire et c'est toujours
la question du calendrier ce que d'une
élection à l'autre on savait que les
hommes et les femmes politiques en un
petit peu de mal à prendre ces choses en
main parce que c'est impopulaire il
arrive quand ce gouvernement qui est
capable de prendre ces choses en moins
je ne suis pas madame irma sait pas
répondre à votre question est ce que je
souhaite c'est que dans les 300 jours
qui viennent des choses utiles soient
soit faite pour vous il ya urgence à
prendre ces choses en main dès
maintenant c'est ce que vous dites vous
me disiez tout à l'heure son rapport à
leur forme des retraites par rapport au
budget où moi je ne suis pas du tout de
ces hommes politiques irresponsables qui
consiste à dire qu'il faut jamais rien
faire parce que il ya des élections
cantonales parce qu'il ya des élections
régionales parce qu'elle élection
présidentielle parce que les élections
législatives si on fait rien sur rien
jamais il faut faire autre chose
c'est-à-dire faut pas faire de politique
donc évidemment quand on doit être
capable de traiter et la question des
retraites et de la question de la
maîtrise d
dépense publique parce que derrière il
ya des situations concrètes il ya des
pme il ya des salariés il ya des
ouvriers il ya des françaises et des
français qui ont besoin que les finances
publiques soient gérées de manière
raisonnable vous savez avant une période
électorale il ya beaucoup de tentations
de démagogie et quand j'écoute certains
candidats à la candidature
présidentielle j'ai l'impression que la
politique du chèque
hoover est à la mode alors faut faire un
chèque ce signe à chaque permis de
conduire un chèque chez pas on va
bientôt pour quasiment proposé pour
acheter son animal de compagnie font
dans la chèques non pardon c'est pas le
monde dans lequel j'ai envie de vivre
j'ai envie que globalement l'état fasse
son job s'investissent beaucoup sur les
questions stratégiques pour le reste on
est quand même pas mal à respirer la
société on va parler dans le sujet on va
parler de la loi antiterroriste soul
avait voté cette loin c'était cette
semaine à l'assemblée comme la majorité
des députés à l'est républicain
mais une partie de votre compte dit
qu'elle ne va pas assez loin
cette loi est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça il aurait fallu aller plus loin
encore bon premièrement il n'ya pas
c'est comme l'argent public il n'y a pas
de lois ou de mesures juridiques magique
en matière de lutte antiterroriste un
jeu je ne pense pas que ce prétexte
qu'on soit dans l'opposition il fallait
dire n'importe quoi j'ai entendu
certaines personnes proposées des peines
automatiques
j'ai entendu quelqu'un dire qu'il
fallait supprimer la peine en matière de
justice pénale fin tout ça est
absolument grotesque
je constate d'ailleurs que c'est souvent
des personnes viennent pas dans
l'hémicycle travailler cette question
j'ai à l'esprit
allez donc j'ai à l'esprit marine le pen
en l'occurrence la présidente du front
national convoi matin midi et soir nous
expliquer qu'elle a des solutions
miracles matière de sécurité et qui ne
daignent pas comme membre de l'assemblée
nationale siéger dans l'hémicycle
s'exprimer peut-être un peu voire même
voter sur les questions de sécurité
d'antiterrorisme c'est absolument
frappant on a passé deux nuits cette
semaine l'assemblée nationale à débattre
sérieusement à que le garde des sceaux
avec le ministre des armées avec le miso
l'intérieur de ces questions qui est
on constate qu'effectivement des gens
qui brillent par leur absence souvent
d'ailleurs parce qu'il brille par leur
incompétence
quand on ne sait qu'à boyer quand on n'a
aucune connaissance technique sur aucun
sujet technique en général on se tire si
vous permettez cette expression
familière et c'est manifestement ce que
font les responsables du du front
national sur le fond j'ai voté ce texte
notamment parce qu'il reprenait de
proposition que j'avais faite voilà dans
le cadre d'un travail parlementaire il
ya un an j'avais présider la mission
d'évaluation sur le renseignement avec
deux députés messieurs kervran et miss
on avait fait des propositions
d'ajustement du cadre juridique de
renseignement ça a été repris par le
gouvernement ça a été voté
c'est pas miraculeux mais c'est
nécessaire pour continuer à ajuster
notre appareil de renseignement nos
services d'espionnage et de contre
espionnage je dis pas que ça va éviter
d'autres attentats ce combat oriane
mancini ce combat c'est le combat d'une
génération
c'est une guerre antiterroriste de 20 25
30 ans que nous avons encore devant nous
elle a commencé il ya une dizaine
d'années avec la compta de mohamed merah
à toulouse en 2012
c'est pas fini on a encore des centaines
de jihadistes sur le territoire national
qui sont prêts à frapper
on a des milliers de personnes qui sont
borderline à la frontière si je veux
dire de la délinquance de droit commun
et et de l'action terroriste c'est un
combat de très longue haleine qui y ont
tous ceux qui vous promettent des
remèdes miracles sur les plateaux de
télé ou sur les matinales de radio dans
la matinale de radio mentent aux
français
et c'est pas respecter les français que
de raconter n'importe quoi sur ces
sujets c'est comme l'arrivée justement
ce guillaume pelletier votre collègue
des républicains a fait une proposition
choc cette semaine c'est le
rétablissement de la cour de sûreté qui
est d'ailleurs aussi une proposition de
marine le pen
il est allé trop loin ou pas je me suis
exprimée dès dimanche soir je ne pense
pas que les nouveaux cri en matière
juridique comme d'ailleurs en matière
économique soit
voie intéressante la proposition de
supprimer la peine en matière de justice
pénale qui a été formulée us il est une
proposition parfaitement absurde dans un
état civilisé on fait pas ça puis en
plus ça n'aurait aucune erreur aucune
efficacité je pense ça veut dire vous
avez parlé de loufoquerie est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin ce que guillaume
pelletier aujourd'hui il peut encore
rester le numéro de votre parti il ya
deux ans il ya eu trois candidats à
l'élection pour la présidence des
républicains
christian jacob le député julie aubert
et et votre serviteur
on a été trois à se présenter devant le
suffrage universel des militants les
militants ont choisi à 60% délire
christian jacob qui fait ce qu'il fait
il le fait plutôt bien pour essayer
d'animer le mouvement c'est de faire
travailler les uns et les autres de
manière aussi rassembleuse que possible
il a nommé un certain nombre d'adjoints
guillaume pelletier d'autres qui sont
qui sont ses adjoints alors univers
divers titres bon je pense que lorsque
ses adjoints font des propositions à
titre personnel il n'engage évidemment
pas le langage évidemment pas le parti
donc ça pose certainement des problèmes
de gouvernance qui à mon avis intéresse
pas trop des français c'est un peu nous
soucier interne on a un comité
stratégique mercredi prochain 9 juin
j'aurai l'occasion bien sûr de
m'exprimer mais qu'est ce que vous allez
dire je pense que après les élections
régionales on devra s'interroger sur la
gouvernance du parti bien sûr mais
concentrons nous d'abord sur l'essentiel
mais parce que ça c'est quand même
synthèse quand même des gens
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui ce parti n'est pas
tenue je fais aucun reproche
mais je veux pas du tout alimenté la
machine à petite polémique interne je
fais aucun reproche à christian jacob
président les républicains comme il est
deux parties et christian jacob il
préside les républicains comme il à le
faire dans une période qui est très
compliqué il essaie de rassembler en
revanche je considère que des personnes
qui ont des responsabilités dans
l'actuelle équipe dirigeante
lorsqu'elle s'exprime à titre personnel
ne devrait pas s'exprimer sa vie
autrefois j'étais porte parole des
républicains au moment de la fondation
par nicolas sarkozy quand vous êtes
porte parole quand vous êtes délégué à
ceci ou à cela vous engager le collectif
avoir le sens du collectif
si vous voulez vous exprimer à titre
personnel vous n'avez pas de
responsabilité au sein de la direction
greffe d'un traitement il ne peut plus
rester vice-président du parti serein on
devra s'interroger sur cette question là
et on devra je pense clarifier les
choses je voudrais pas qu'on soit
parasité pendant l'année qui vient par
des déclarations loufoques qui qui qui
qui n'ont pas lieu d'être
bien sûr pouvoir reconnaissez encore
dans l'est républicain mais bien sûr
écouter avons posé la question à chaque
fois et je vous en remercie mais je suis
membre de ce mouvement qui a été fondée
par les héritiers du général de gaulle
qui a toute une philosophie politique
est aussi celle des libéraux
voilà ajoute ensuite été le cas aussi de
bruno le maire auquel vous trouvé
beaucoup de mérite vous disais à
l'instant oui il y en a d'autres mais
c'est le jeu des objets et pourriez
aussi vous retrouver une certaine france
de la république en marge par exemple
non mais je l ai la république en marche
c'est parti assez étrange jeu c'est de
ne pas de secteur si vous voulez c'est
difficile ou dans ce monde où il faut
être en noir et blanc dans le monde de
la polémique permanente dans le monde
des tweets dans le monde
extrême dans lequel on est aujourd'hui
je sais pas être secteur je sais où
j'habite je suis membre des républicains
il ya beaucoup de personnes de talent
sympathique
voilà il ya aussi des parfois des
divergences qui devront un jour bien sûr
être être être tranchée disons les
choses c'est un parti qui est en crise
structurelle depuis quand depuis depuis
2010 est pour la bonne raison et on va
pas refaire l'histoire partie a été
éliminé en tout cas son représentant au
second tour élection présidentielle
depuis quatre ans c'est évidemment très
secoués je peux faire deux le nombre
d'espacés sur le sertit qui n'a manqué
ni guillaume larrivé parce qu'on a parlé
de cette déclaration sur la justice
d'exception de 2 millions pelletier qui
a été plutôt condamné d'ailleurs par
l'ensemble des républicains en revanche
il a aussi dit qu'il y avait une
convergence d'idées avec robert ménard
il a aussi remis en cause le front
républicain
est-ce que là c'est pas plutôt
révélateur de deux lignes qui sont
peut-être irréconciliables désormais il
ya évidemment des divergences qui ne
sont pas que des divergences de
personnes ça devra être tranché ça ne
l'est pas aujourd'hui ce que j'aimerais
et là dessus je suis d'accord et
christian jacob j'aimerais qu'on se
concentre dans les seize jours qui
viennent sur les sur les élections
nationales et les élections régionales
du front républicain
ou est-ce que vous allez trancher alors
qu'il ya deux ministres et rentrent dans
votre parti on est on est moyennement de
fini je le dis en étant tout à fait à
l'aise savez il faut marcher un pas
après l'autre et c'est pas de la langue
de bois on est avant le premier tour et
c'est là d'ailleurs où guillaume tell
qui a eu tort de dire n'importe quoi sur
un tas de sujets y compris des sujets
économiques ou le proposera un mode
il faut se concentrer sur les batailles
qu'on a menées en l'occurrence on est
dans un premier tour
moi ce que je souhaite c'est que les
candidats que nous soutenons dans toutes
les régions de france fasse évidemment
le maximum de voix parce que il ya des
projets régionaux qui sont portées par
des gens de qualité que ce soit dans la
région sud en ile de france et haute
france en bourgogne en bretagne que les
aborder de manière à fait beats et
régionales on va pas se mentir le michel
barnier le disait cette place hier on a
été parasitée ces dernières semaines par
des débats qui n'aurait pas dû qui
n'aurait pas dû exister
je ferai ce soir aillant sur tholon une
petite réunion
dans mon département avec les candidats
que ce soutien aux élections régionales
on va parler des sujets et territoriaux
on va parler d'été heures on va parler
de la sécurité aux abords des lycées on
va parler des questions régionales à des
questions aussi écologique régionales on
va pas parler des dernières déclarations
de monsieur pelletier et c'est sur qu'il
faudrait éviter de ce parasite et de se
pourrir la vie nous mêmes par des sujets
qui ne doivent pas je pense être à
l'agenda les médias oui vous confortez
quand même l'opinion dans l'idée que je
sais régionales c'est une forme de
primaires pour la présidentielle a
indiqué jeudi exactement le contraire
pour moi les régionales sont des
élections régionales c'est assez
original de le dire mais je pense que
tous ceux qui nationalise compris dans
la majorité présidentielle
tous ceux qui nationalise les régionales
se trompent je suis ici au sénat dans la
chambres des collectivités territoriales
il faut prendre les collectivités
territoriales au sérieux je voudrais pas
que ces élections soient prises en hold
up par la précampagne présidentielle de
madame le pen ou par des déclarations
intempestives qui cherche un candidat
oui mais précisément il faudra faire ça
plus tard pour moi la question de la
candidature est pour voir faire ça dans
la foulée des régionales où est ce que
vous pouvez encore attendre l'automne
moi je pense que cette au début de
l'année 2022 que se cristallisent ces
questions vous c'est après l'automne en
ski en ce qui me concerne je ferai mon
choix au début de l'année 2022 et vous
pouvez vous permettre d'attendre jusque
là pour avoir un candidat
en tout cas les élections
présidentielles sont 2022 elles sont pas
en 2021 cette espèce d'obsession des uns
des autres pour l'élection
présidentielle me par extraits
div moi j'aime bien faire les choses
dans l'ordre et je pense que c'est aussi
plutôt ce que plus tôt fin je pense que
c'est plutôt ce que pense la majorité
des des français prenons les choses dans
l'ordre et essayons de rester sérieux et
merci beaucoup merci c'est arrivé d'être
une over ce matin on regarde la une de
l'est républicain
fabrice ça et c'est ce fait m'initier
dans le dramatique féminicide qui a eu
lieu hier à metz et oui j'ai mis dix
idées là ce qui poursuivent leur chemin
en france et on note d'ailleurs que
l'homme qui avait agressé cette femme la
mère de ses trois enfants est décédé
cette nuit mars
[Musique]